big fan of this man's work and throw to
half right here on the rich eisen show
his
film edge of the world is available on
digital and demand today the friendship
onion podcast is
hosted by him and billy billy boyd and
available wherever you get your podcasts
to talk about
the great lord of the rings trilogy that
he was involved in uh i was also a big
fan of his
for the terrific tv show lost dominic
monahan here on the rich eisen show how
are you sir
what's happening rich lovely to speak to
you good to chat with you how have i
where have i found you
are you driving around this great city
of los angeles right now i am currently
driving um in los angeles i'm just
driving through los
vila's village past the old dresden i'm
heading to see
a friend okay fantastic um how's the i
should feel i should ask
you how the weather is so you could do
traffic and weather together but i know
it's a beautiful day here in los angeles
california
it is you got that going it's just
starting to warm up i have to admit i
my favorite time in los angeles is
probably
december january february when it rains
a lot and
then you know the clouds are a little
gloomy once it starts getting hot and
sunny
it's a little it's a little too much is
that so does that remind you of home
when it's gloomy outside is that what
you're saying dominic
yeah i come from a city in the north of
england called manchester where all the
football and music comes from
and um the weather there doesn't tend to
get over
kind of 75 80 degrees and it rains for
probably eight months of the year it's
glorious so now dominic monahan if you
were back home
in manchester about let's what was this
about six weeks ago
would you been one of those fans out
there uh
railing against the super league would
you have done that dominic
well i i very much protested against the
european super league on my social media
channels unfortunately i couldn't get to
manchester because of
you know the covid restrictions
requirements but
yeah the the european super league would
have absolutely destroyed
not only english football but it would
have destroyed german italian
french dutch all of the football leagues
in europe
as long as well as the champions league
the europa league
it would have destroyed modern day
soccer as we know it so i was
permanently against so how were you for
that 48-hour period where it looked like
it was actually gonna happen
i was extremely worried especially when
my team manchester united were kind of
at the forefront of talking about it
actually happening it wasn't as if they
were saying
we're considering this and we're
thinking about it they just announced
this thing is happening and it took the
players by surprise it took the manager
by surprise
and it took all the fans by surprise so
i was i was deeply worried and concerned
i think aside from actual physical
tragedies that have taken place in
soccer like hillsborough
and and the high soul tragedy this was
probably the most seismic piece of news
ever in soccer for me well as you know
spending time in the states
uh you know zipping around los feliz as
you are doing right now
uh dominic uh all of us americans and i
appreciate using the word soccer for
this audience but
uh i appreciate but uh for all all the
soccer fans here and seeing
what was going on in the you know the
football world
um in that regard uh it does not compute
that fans railing against business
interests would actually wind up with
the fans winning
it's really confusing to us here in
america
dominic i i i have to admit it was it
was probably
it started out as as a real awful piece
of news and then ended up being a hugely
positive movement because
as you say rich you know the fans
basically said we
are not going to put up with this and
they protested and they rallied and they
made their voice heard
and it completely did a 180 on
on what the managers wanted to do so it
ended up being a fantastic story
to just to touch upon american sports
for for a moment like
you know obviously i've lived in los
angeles now for about 15 years yep
big fan of the lakers i love the dodgers
i followed kevin garnett for a while
because i love the i love the way that
he played that kind of
fall away jumper that he used to uh
shoot um
you know i'll watch um the super bowl i
like i went to um
i went to the um the college playoffs
for the basketball the final the final
four i went to arizona state
university so any big sporting event i'm
there an american sport
they really do it well they put a ribbon
on it they make it big and brash and
exciting and i'm here for it
what do you mean they put a ribbon on it
what do you mean by that they just
they go big did i mean they go big like
i love the fact that
you know in england we we support our
teams but outside of that saturday
there's not a massive amount going on we
get ready for that saturday the game's
over and it's done and we wait for the
next saturday but it feels like
over here you know in the united states
it's it's more of a
big kind of thing there's big parties
and celebrations and you know we don't
do that tailgating thing that you guys
do i love that whole tailgating
community it's brilliant
there's no tailgating in manchester not
at all
we all drink it we all drink in the pubs
the pubs are open
get drunk and then we walk to the
stadium i'll take one last shot here
on this subject matter have you seen ted
lasso have you seen any of that
dominic have you seen action yes i have
seen that last time
i'm actually friends with the guy called
brett goldstein the kind of swabby
looking uh dark
bearded guy who who is kind of a good
player on the ted lasso team
he's a friend of mine i did his podcast
how real of a portrayal is roy kent how
uh dominic how real of a portrayal
is that it's difficult to
to um kind of encapsulate
football or soccer as you guys call it
on on
screen in the same way that i think it's
been problematic over the years to try
and capture
what competitive basketball looks like
or competitive
american football i will say i think the
friday night friday night light
film and tv show was superb and
you know there's been some other notable
mentions but for the most part i think
it's difficult to capture
sport in the moment because it's so
frenetic and it's so
improvised you know dominic monaghan
here on the rich eisen show
uh let's dive into your work sir um
starting with lost that show
was so transformative for me that first
season in particular
was perfect i don't think there was a
note off when you first received a
script did you have any idea what was
going to come
smoke monsters what they were anything
of that regard dominic walk me through
that
now we didn't know anything about smoke
monsters but and thank you for the
compliment but i will i will say that
um it was it was easily the
best pilot script that i've ever read
like
even up until this point and it for my
money
you know i don't tend to brag about my
career too much but when people say to
me
um can you recommend something that
you've done that i might not have seen
sometimes i will say have you seen lost
and if they say i know
i missed it and it's six seasons long
and i know it's not great and i'll
always say to them
look for my money it's one of the best
first seasons of the show ever ever i
agree
and then at times you know the second
season it goes in a strange direction
and maybe season four and five
it might be a bit tricky but season one
i would put that up against the twilight
zone and put it up against star trek and
the sopranos it's incredible that's not
just because you lived in hawaii to
shoot it right dominic correct
that's not the only reason
that had to be something else too that
ought to be quite i mean you've been all
over this globe
shooting uh your films and tv shows
um and that so why do the
uh front the uh friendship onion podcast
why
dive into the lord of the rings trilogy
again what what attracted you to that
idea
dominic well you know the great
the great friend that i've made in my
life in this business
has been billy boyd i obviously have
made great acquaintances and other great
friend in my life but the person that's
at the top of that list
is billy boyd you know we're kind of
separated at birth type
vibes and and we spend a huge amount of
time with each other and i just made
mention to him
probably about 18 months ago i just said
look then these conversations that we
have
about what's your favorite cheese or
what would you do if you're in a hot air
balloon and it just kept
going higher and higher and higher i
said if we have two mics running at the
same time
that's a podcast that's what people
listen to i had to get billy up to a
point to
figure out that a podcast can just be
people kind of aimlessly talking about
nothing in particular and then every so
often
fall back on the lord of the rings and
um you know it seems to be doing okay
we're the number one film and tv podcast
in the world for the last uh
three weeks running so we're doing
something right well i mean it's a very
popular subject matter
you got a good ian mckellen story what
do you got for me on the set anything
good
oh man i mean most
mcallen stories are kind of bordering on
illegal so
gandalf did something illegal gandalf
did something illegal
he you know ian mckellen when we were
doing lord rings
ian mckellen was 67 i was 23 and ian
mckellen was out with all of the boys
until
two or three in the morning partying and
having fun so a lot of those stories
kind of
get vaulted but i'll tell you a funny
story when we did this josh gad
podcast yes before it all kicked off we
were all on this zoom call
and i had said to ian mckellen just just
happened to mention to him i said hey
ian
did you ever get a poster of lord of the
rings
that was signed by the entire cast you
know how sometimes they'll do that with
cash they'll make sure that everyone
gets a signed poster from everyone so
you can frame it in your office
and uh ian michael said no i i never got
one of those lord rings podcast
posters but he said i've got about 300
cats
posters if you want one what the hell
what does that mean you know that movie
cats that he was in oh god that one
she's
well i mean we had sean aston on the
show and i'm uh i'm a michigan wolverine
fan so i despise notre dame football
and i i started denigrating rudy the
player that he uh portrayed in that film
and he cursed at me on live television
and radio that happened with sean aston
he cursed it yeah he can get very
passionate about things sean you know he
believes in certain things you know we
um
it's been great because obviously we
played a fellowship in lord of the rings
but we have really kind of
created this fellowship brotherhood in
real life all four hobbits
are on are on this uh message speed
that's been going on for uh for a long
time
we all make sure we find out when people
are in town
in los angeles in london when anyone's
birthday is we all
we all you know get in touch with each
other so it's continued on and on and
it's a beautiful thing to be associated
an actual fellowship of the ring
right there i like that uh
and then lastly the edge of the world uh
edge of the world film that is available
on digital and demand today what do you
want folks to know about
this film that you are in sir edge of
the world is a true story
about a man called james brook in the
18th century who
sails from england to borneo which is
the largest uh
island in asia and um kind of falls in
love with the island and becomes the
first raja which is essentially a king
and then there's a lot of kind of
political issues that come up and his
his physical safety is is at question
and i play
um james brooke played by jonathan rees
knight i play his kind of
number one guy his assistant is
confident
his counsel a guy called crookshank so
it's a true story about a man that's
kind of
stuck between two worlds it was the
inspiration for the film the man who
would be killing and also
quite inspirational of joseph conrad's
heart of darkness so it's a great film
in an amazing part of the world that we
shot just before lockdown
about a month before lockdown we
finished it wow uh and that's again
that's uh available on digital and
demand today and i that's what i wanted
to know about
for let people know because edge of the
world was not about the premier league
for 48 hours
in the month of may that's what you're
saying correct
that's not what it is who would you have
portrayed in that film uh dominick who
would you have portrayed in that film
just a regular fan
going on just in the story of the
european civil league yes
exactly what would you have played if
that effect would i mean
who would i who would i like to be or
who would like i mean i think i would
probably end up being a fan but who
would i like to be i mean
i'd like to portray someone like juan
mata
or wayne rooney or ryan giggs or eric
cantona i'm a die-hard manchester united
fan so any of those luminary manchester
united players you know
wayne rooney i mean my gosh you must
yeah
just live i mean i would love to watch a
world cup match with you
i would love to do that that would be oh
yeah well we've got the euros coming up
in in a week or so so the euros is
obviously just like the world cup but
it's only europeans that play
england england probably are in the top
three or four
strongest teams on paper they usually
choke in the big competition
we'll see how they do this time i think
for my money i think probably france
they're gonna win it or belgium
but fingers crossed uh you know england
go deep in it dominic i'd love to have
you on
whenever you want to talk about this and
other subjects i'm a big fan and uh
thanks for the call appreciate it
i appreciate that rick that'd be great
to meet you in person let's do it that's
dominic monahan
right here on the rich eyes and show
edges of the world available on digital
and demand today
you get the friendship onion podcast
about him talking about lord of the
rings
where all podcasts are acquired at
domswildthings on twitter at
dom underscore monahan underscore on
instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here